greetings from podcast Ville its Monday
the 25th of November get your [ __ ]
together the Church of what's happening
now is brought to you by my bookie
listen attention attention past present
and future my bookie plays this
Thanksgiving Day you could get in a game
risk-free if the pilgrims could sail to
America you could take a chance on the
Bears Lions game either way you're not
losing excuse me do this either way
you're not losing Gators this
Thanksgiving Day only choose a team
against the spread up to 250 dollars if
you win you got some cash for the
holidays and if you lose you also win
cuz my bookie will give you your money
back let me repeat that's a guaranteed
deposit match and risk-free bet for
Thanksgiving only so if you're a true
football fan I mean a real [ __ ]
football fan you don't want to let this
opportunity pass you by stop waiting in
the sidelines stop sitting there like a
[ __ ] mutt this is the prime time to
make money now you got this game and the
next week is mole season you got
basketball you got college basketball
you got em behave action you got
everything coming at you and the most
importantly is you got my bookie doll AG
so go to my bookie dot AG use promo code
shirt CH you are CH and get in on the
[ __ ] action this year you play you
win you get paid the church is also
brought to you by my pushy listen I
would work on my toes you for three is
listo has is I still have mine they're
[ __ ] tremendous do you understand me
why walk around with that stinky [ __ ]
[ __ ] on Thanksgiving this is the time
of the year that you want to feel good
about yourself it starts from within
from your [ __ ] your nutsack all that
type of [ __ ] but start with mine with
tushy you're like why Joey go to a
little douchey right now and look at the
great selection of the days they got
starting at $69 they even come with a
[ __ ] guarantee but there's no
guarantee and I mean they're what the
guarantee is Lee and Joey have had one
for the last [ __ ] three years and
they still work and they haven't broken
so if our fat asses haven't [ __ ] it up
what did you
skinny little bony stinky ass waiting
for go to hell old pushy
calm right now press in church and get
10% off your order
the church is also brought to you by CBD
line calm listen this last week I
injured myself really [ __ ] bad and
the reason why I was easy for me to
sleep at night would be to CBD Lyon calm
I took the tension and I rubbed it on my
thigh three four [ __ ] times a day
they got a rollerball now it comes like
that eucalyptus flavored do it like a
mint you roll it on the back of your
[ __ ] leg listen CBD Lyon a and stop
and they take K you with the [ __ ]
paper pens no II know vitamin E
accelerating man whatever the [ __ ]
chemical is that's making kick off their
lungs on they got the shatter they got
the tension they got the raspberry
[ __ ] gummies they got the roll-on
CBD line calm go look at the third-party
test results yourself online go to CBD
line calm right now
press in church and get 20% off your
first order right who takes care you
Thanksgiving week nobody kick this
[ __ ] mealy what's happening you bad
mother [ __ ] this Thanksgiving week just
think 2,000 years ago right now today
pilgrims the Stabbin Indians in the
heart with pencils and [ __ ] trying to
take their [ __ ] corn and [ __ ]
so when you're eating your little
[ __ ] turkey
don't forget about nothing Donnell talk
to me baby what's happening I celebrate
every holiday I know you just dismissed
that evil holida holiday of Thanksgiving
and how it started but me growing up I
liked any holiday that you didn't have
to go to school for me through Chris I
ain't know who the [ __ ] Christopher
Columbus was I didn't give a [ __ ]
George why shouldn't presidents day
Christopher Columbus any day a lot of
those holidays was all after white
people and no disrespect to the black
community but I was so happy those white
people who was able to give me a date I
had to go to school
remember wooden used to be Lincoln and
Washington Day yeah it was the 19th yeah
you had up to Mondays in a row then they
got hip to it and they cut it down to
presidents [ __ ] and then when Barack
got elected a Kyrie the holiday all
again this year
now then they got rid of Columbus Day
which I knew was gonna be a busy gonna
backfire right because that means gonna
stop they're gonna start changing
[ __ ] days all the time oh yeah
Columbus once you [ __ ] with Columbus now
they want to change Halloween what are
you gonna change all the way Saturday
the last Saturday at a month so the kids
don't eat sugar during the week is that
like some legislation or something no
that's [ __ ] Gentiles okay who makes up
this yeah so they they always want to
change some [ __ ] but man let me tell you
something huh for 20 [ __ ] years I've
been watching you I'm like I wonder what
Street in Harlem he's from me yeah I
always thought you were from [ __ ]
Harlem now Brooklyn and then the other
day you from Brooklyn but not well most
of I'm really from Washington DC
Virginia
yeah but for the most part I was when I
started six months into it I broke out
of DC and I moved to New York so I
consider that my second home I've
considered that's the home of my career
but that's my second home in like what
year did you start comedy it probably
was like 96 97
no [ __ ] yeah it was right when black
comedy was on fire fire and went what
made you did you think about it I never
thought about I never thought about
doing comedy but I was always the
funniest dude in the room you know I've
told this story before I was in the
military I was and I was a police
officer in the military and I got out of
the UH I got on the military and I was
waiting to be a DC police officer nice
to work for his grocery chain I was head
of security and I was the guy who used
to work for a hostess cupcake company
and he was the day job he didn't quit a
day job he was hostess do it in the
daytime and then a comedian at night he
would give out free passes to get people
to go and I used to go with a lot of
people I worked with and I started
heckling I was heckling people I was
hacking the [ __ ] out of people I mean I
was happily we're proposals coming up to
me saying yo chill man I'm trying to
work on this set for so I was like man
[ __ ] out of here
you do your job I'm gonna do my job and
I did that so long that people started
to come to the comedy club to hear me
heckle and I was so naive because I went
to the club on and I was like look look
I didn't increase y'all business about
30% I try to get a door deal
Hepler yeah I was like man look at the
numbers that I'm bringing in they'd look
like what the [ __ ] are you talking about
what club was it this was comedy
connection to greenbelt no like and I
did this time in the 90s or late
nineties it was like black comedy was it
was it was poppin so hard that it wasn't
comedy clubs but it'll be like a pizza
shop yeah you know like they usually
have slow business on a Monday or a
Tuesday they would start at night and
then they were find it was finding out
that you know these little small comedy
hubs turned into comedy clubs Monique
she did she did she flipped a restaurant
in Baltimore when she first started from
a struggling restaurant she had a comedy
night on a Thursday and it was doing so
well her door was doing great the food
was doing great everything was doing
great business wasn't doing well on the
weekends and she turned it over and
flipped it when she cooked at least and
she turned into one of the a black
comedy club in Baltimore and that's not
a comedy connection in Grain Belt it was
a spot did the need for black comedy was
so overwhelming that anybody could just
open up and say you know we got black
comedy we got Def Jam Carly you know so
I went on they they they wanted me to
shut the [ __ ] up I didn't shut the [ __ ]
up you know one day you say what you
going
and I was like I'd like it on this side
yeah you know I'm like no I don't want
that pressure and I didn't do it that
week and then I went and I did that week
I went wrote what I thought was a half
hour worth of material you know you
first start you think you look at a city
like oh that's gonna give me a minute
that's gonna get a minute and that ain't
got nothing to do with nobody laughing
at the [ __ ] you being nervous and
forgetting the [ __ ] and I practice
without those I wasn't having said in
the a week after that I went on stage I
caught a standing over the first time I
would touch the mic and I'm sure part of
it but it wasn't just that I was super
funny but because I had such a history
in that Club people were really rooting
for me see they wanted to they wanted me
to graduate from being a heckler and the
only thing next to do is go on stage and
that day I never looked back I was like
dis [ __ ] being a cop I'm doing this [ __ ]
as I know you how long were you in the
service for four years and you were
stationed in Korea I was stationed
across South Korea what'd you think
loved it when I first when I went in
when military when I was 17 so my mother
actually had to sign a private parental
consent to fight for my country and for
me it was a good transition because I
hadn't I've never been on an airplane
I've never been on the side of
Alexandria area culturally it was great
you know for me not really being trained
in anything or have any skills and for
most black people that's a that's a good
option to just being a street person to
going to jail you know said probably the
first time some people get credit cards
first time you see anything so that
experience of me leaving home was
incredible I met some good friends of
basic training met some good friends in
tech school my first duty station was
Kunsan Korea I met some people that I
still considered to be a couple of my
closest friends for years I met some
good people and I got to go to a place
and they're in a whole different culture
a whole way of life a whole different
how people look at people and it kind of
opened me up to look at the world
different from that person that would
have just been you know on a corner
talking [ __ ] rolling dice and smoking
weed and [ __ ] why didn't you stay in I
didn't stay in because I had a
discipline problem and it wasn't enough
to uh I would have kept getting in
trouble I wasn't built for four years
was good for me like um I had issue with
respect I guess I went too bad you
didn't like how you were spoken I just
didn't like anybody just because you
outrank me being able to say any
photography the way a walker and there's
some people like was abusive with it you
know saying like you know I would rather
you talk to me like a man first but not
like somebody that you know that you
that works for him you know and I just
it wasn't it was it was a good
transition for me not doing anything my
life with fine is something to do and it
was just time for me to move on you know
I had some good experience and a mess of
good people but I wasn't built to be
running right out of bunkers and
don't in fact if I had to protect this
country a lot of people who got killed
said we used to do exercises when you
simulate war so you simulate like what
would happen if you under attack but you
know North Korea whatever and when you
get killed you get killed they come and
pick you up in this van or this truck
this Duke deuce I think it's gonna do
and they take you to the gym and when
you get to the gym while you did you get
to play basketball right so man it was a
no black people that battleground son it
was all white people with camouflage
make-up on all of they face hide behind
trees that [ __ ] black doodles in the
Jimmy and three-pointers man we was like
[ __ ] that war so I was a served my
country but I wasn't like super
patriotic ah yeah but you know I did at
56 you know that's one of my biggest
regrets that one it's a motor why it was
my mother's dream I saw you from
military um know what she felt she was
Cuban and she felt that the United
States gave her a chance and took the R
in that the least she could do is all
for her son to fight for this country so
she used to never shut the [ __ ] up about
really yeah she never used that's a dumb
story but what's really crazy to me is
you know okay you come to me and you go
Joey
my name is Don now I'm thinking it's
doing stand-up I'm gonna die now you
know what are you doing for work I'm
working raps I stuffed shells I make 18
an hour I get benefits a go rally
someone to a plant we're gonna get you
some open mics bah bah bah and then you
know transition you know look at me and
say cut it out negro right how much am I
gonna make and how long is it gonna take
exactly I'm gonna look at you say 10
years right to be conservative let's go
for 10 years before you make a dime
that's not another 10 [ __ ] ago
10 years all right yeah and then one day
you find yourself you're 34 years old
and you go [ __ ] I should if I would have
got into that when I was and what am I
done with my life but you know but you
look look how you free that happens for
a reason
and I get it but man the idea of walking
out of a [ __ ] when you're 38
with full retirement balance you know
you're so funny you say that joy because
I actually have that sometime I have
that I dream about that thought I dream
that's my dream yeah and I was like this
cuz I went in when I was 17 and I look
at it I always that's the one thing but
it's a difference from gone from
therefore to that 20 right talking here
we just talking like that for talking
I'm looking at 16 plus and I'm looking
at a military day always yelling at me
right your blatant disregard for
established military policy that's every
day I've get a letter of level letter a
reprimands even I was miss cheevus I've
got a little trouble but in the military
they want you to be for the most part
squeaky clean and even if you're not is
so much harder to get stripes is so much
harder to get to accolades you need and
I'm the same way I thought like you
thought I thought about that 20-year
joint but therefore one was such as go
grind for me I couldn't go to next 16
man but I respect the people that do it
and even I meet people in like man I was
in military like man think how busy that
would't might not have been the path to
like 17 go in 20 years later get out 38
you really especially black don't crack
I really could have started a stand-up
career then getting 7 grand a month yeah
with the best insurance in the world
yeah you know all you have to do to go
down there they'll give you a bad teeth
right there right you know anything you
know I mean you have to just think about
it yeah and a lot of young kids listen
to these podcasts right and you really
have to explain come then let me tell
you something man I'm 56
I still remember being 36 right that 20
went by quick in the mother [ __ ] they
don't see it man I stopped that I let
slept on couches you know I took
Greyhound buses all that what's the
difference the only thing I didn't do
was get shot at I'm so [ __ ] to do
with a towel or through [ __ ] a
grenade at me but but in my heart I felt
like it right when you [ __ ] had a
Greyhound station with four dollars in
your pocket man
I did when I used to when I when I um
when I found my love for comedy I was
like this what I'm gonna be doing for
the rest of my life and I was I had a
pretty decent job job I had benefits
everything you talked about you know
like you know you'll come up and my come
up not too far like not far apart in a
sense of the first thing you want to do
is be able to provide for yourself
first thing you wanna do like you said
benefits and let me get some some
regular [ __ ] in a square as out
lifestyle as squares I might think of it
and I know probably in like I know you
like you know could I have been a square
[ __ ] you know I'm saying could I
have been and that's that's not a bad
life at all and for a lot of people the
military that that's what it provide it
provided that transition for you to have
a decent life 20 years I was like if I
started like I said 20 years ago
38 start is all over you know you could
think that have been a perfect situation
but then you know everything happens and
if you tell and I was on the buses when
I moved when I moved from DC to New York
I moved to DC to New York but thirty
five dollars in my pocket I had my
military duffle bag and an alarm clock
and my man Roy Watkins where Watkins had
already done def Comedy Jam so he was
under Russell Simmons umbrella managed
by rest communications bob sumner what
year is this this is like 97 90 okay so
he already got it pop it like four foot
four DC comic to hear about another
comic moving to New York
cuz everybody took that [ __ ] and
everybody I was every excuse I need the
same amount of money that I'm gonna go
up here you make a million excuses you
know you making a music man excuse us
well I gotta do this I gotta get my set
together no [ __ ] you gotta get
on that bus girl that boy can I know he
was trying to Punk me every time I see
him hit this thing was happy she didn't
development the other he'll come up in
New York can one day I called him I said
ma'am were in New York he was like when
I said Friday [ __ ] and I went on
it got down Peter Pan to be parent
railway at that time for me it was $19
and it was when I first
I wasn't getting no stage time so you
know when you leave a certain place your
money you like a popular name in DC so I
was still a part of the DC scene still
during the cabaret so if when I was
broke I would dip down to DC to do a
show for like $500 with $20 in my pocket
knowing I had to go for this it's nice
to have money up and then come back and
keep on grinding till people start to
take notice and yeah I started to be
able to do the same hustle in New York
when she moved to Brooklyn I moved to
Brooklyn Britt was the first borough
moved to what's the first comedy clever
you want to attend first comedy no no I
went pips it was like it was um I was
steal from the black circuit so I didn't
even really go to when I first won New
York I didn't go to calm because I went
to black nights like Boston comedy club
was pretty much the drain straight
economy cellar was mainstream catch
arises star was mainstream and out of
all the comics in New York it was
probably only probably three or four
percent of the black comments working in
mainstream rooms you just couldn't get
in can the only way you could get in you
know you had to be first vouched by
somebody else you know but we're waiting
to get passed and all that there was
just comedy nights you like Def Con
reman Jam night comedy explosion eyes so
those are the stages and I performed it
first mainstream comical about winning
two was the Boston Comedy Club and that
was because it was a black night on
Sunday and when I moved and I was happy
with just doing the black circuit
because you can make a perfect living it
was like so many rooms that were open
like you can make a grand a week
you know the grander you could make it
like yeah despite you there like six or
seven spice you doing a buck 25 each
joint you can make a grand a week for a
comic that's not married don't have no
responsibilities and rooming with
somebody that was decent and that was
probably one of the reasons why a lot of
black comics had an issue with crossing
over or doing Main Street because they
got so comfortable with making a decent
living in a black circuit but not
understanding that was in the future
you know I'm saying that was temporary
one of the things that I start I got on
stage in 91 I didn't get serious till 93
and a young brother saw me and then I
was in Denton his name is Kwame and I
think about him a lot because I wouldn't
be if it wasn't for him he threw me into
a den of thieves
yeah he had a black man on he's Colfax
and you went up and this is where this
is what he's Koufax was flag hookers
syringes crack pipes and it was calling
you know black explosion on Sunday right
and he would book comedians to fly in
and I got to meet which these
relationships are still intact this is
94 right I got to meet DL Bernie they
were smoking back then said young yes
Steve Harvey you know I'm sure I met all
the ones I don't remember but so it was
a black night was a black night right
and they only allowed two white comics
and they were loud in that uh uh and
this fall so are you Denver okay so with
me and a white dude that you guys know
his name is dr. Kevin Fitzgerald he's a
veterinarian well on Animal Planet he's
a big white dude a man who saves animals
and stuff he's a stand-up oh yeah in
real life
so like Kwame was a solid brother let
him go bro you know everybody's welcome
right but not everybody was welcome cuz
you go down and they drove [ __ ] at you
man I know though so I figured out that
for me to go up on stage I have to come
out dancing first right so I put on like
SWV and I come out dance and SWV and
then I have to attack oh yeah this is a
you know two years intercom yeah I had
to jump into them like look at this
[ __ ] my we lookin [ __ ] to let
them know look at this guy looks like
Archie bail when you start random shots
right you have to attack them yeah and I
would have three jokes but the first ten
minutes was look at this even with that
said and but when you got him how good
did it feel
ripping it are you still remember
getting off stage and listen I was doing
me three years now I could tell you
whatever the [ __ ] you want me to tell
you I was eating a bag of dicks
but for seven minutes I was making my
soul stronger yeah
because not too many people would do
that not too many people going to an
african-american room never mind go that
a bomb and be up first
i'ma tell you I saw the first two and
you wonders it records when I started
coming to Greenville Def Jam was hot so
like you said all those names you named
Bernie Mac D early you Chris Tucker
Eddie Griffith shucky ducky I mean so
many so it was just it was so many you
were just black on a black on black on
and the first time I ever saw a white
dude go into this room and just straight
demolish it it was rich Voss yeah man
let me tell you I said this month had a
ponytail back there sir and I was saying
he was going so hard at these brothers I
was like oh he bought me his shot but
but but the thing about it was he didn't
back down
he was like bam bam bam vishwas was the
first white guy on def Comedy Jam
yes and Betty T awful and I always tell
always tell whenever I run so I was like
man I've never seen a white dude with a
ponytail go into a black room like that
and just eat him up but the love you get
it was it was a handful to come like a
DC bitty out of DC he was wanting to do
is and where do ya ya Puerto Rican dude
Rican woman well in whites right oh and
uh bill burr bill burr when he first
moved to Boston bill burr was heavy or
the black circuit and then you know he
did a Messer Square Garden we've had the
black community haven't seen him since
no but bill was one of those dudes that
would go eat up any room black from
white room and I tell like I mid-tour
die sometimes you don't get all type of
comic friends with and more so like with
my white common friends when they like
telling say like hard me to get stage
time stuff I was like you know what you
should do I say start doing black rooms
and they look at me like I'm like why I
say because most black robes gonna put
you on just to see you fail
and even if that's how you get on stage
at least you get on stage and then when
you get on stage you flip it and show
something you figure it out you figured
out like you we so used to be in an
environment where it's comfortable and
easy and follow back like you said first
room I went the first places I performed
outside of the black room there was a
poetry scene was really hot in Brooklyn
at the time they had this spot called
Brooklyn moon cafe it was when porch she
was like really popping where they was
doing this the snaps and [ __ ] and dudes
was getting [ __ ] just by you know
burning the right instance drinking the
right tea just telling [ __ ] I love your
energy
you know saying like I'm connected to
your soul they was [ __ ] I'm herbal
chicks in the bathroom the same way the
peppers do it I'm into your soul my
sister and a law you say sister that's
the longer you be the [ __ ] up say like
oh my god did you see mr. knowledge and
I when I couldn't get on the stage I was
like now I gotta perform somewhere and I
would go cuz that [ __ ] used to be so
boring but this spot was so hot like
most def used to go dear
[ __ ] Talib used to go dear Eric
Erykah Badu's goodie when she was not
Erykah Badu like literally like she's
gonna spotlight moving to Brooklyn like
like being if like three weeks it's just
hot spot and I was like man this [ __ ] is
so Drabek and use some jokes and I felt
like the fish out of what I was like you
know can I get up there was a you poor
people like you a poet and I'm like yeah
and I grew up they be like I want to say
did that go into a set and I became I
started getting properly in the under
poet you seen outside wait a minute I
can't get on stage these poets she's
supposed to be so dead and dry I could
be known as the comedian that come shake
up the poetry singer I would do all and
that's what and that's what I was like I
don't know we think a lot in terms of
how you get better you know I'm saying
always sharpen sharpen the sword you
know your age and I my age you know for
this is not being cocky or anything but
we've been holding out weight for a long
time Allah
through types of technologies man VHS
beta we remember all of that [ __ ]
[ __ ] VHS beta CD cd-rom blu-ray
Lynx that's a lot of [ __ ] years
of technology son that's a lot of and
not better and I say that cause these
[ __ ] like to talk a lot [ __ ]
old man all that type of [ __ ] but see
how long a muffin can hold a weight and
not just pity party like yeah I saw much
so and so so I gave him a couple
chuckles I'll talk about know about the
[ __ ] pound-for-pound let's go and
don't do that no more they don't they
don't they don't do the United says you
gotta be there every night but you gotta
stay sharp you gotta get on if you're a
comedy fiend that's what I am when your
mind switches into that comedy fan mode
where life isn't even life anymore
your whole life is riding watching or
getting on stage right it's a part of
your career where for me it was the
three-year mark uh well for three years
I didn't know what was popular on TV I
didn't know what it was in it I rented
the DDT - how many alternate tape with
Martin and doing the warm-up with Joe
Torre huh and I rented Rodney
Dangerfield's young comedians special
with dice and Bill Hicks and if I wasn't
on stage writing I was watching those
two things that not I'm now studying
moves and gestures man like a young
brother from New York that was killing
in New York when you went back in 94
he's still around
oh good-looking young brother bill bet
now bill bill Pelham yeah yeah it was
like the king of New York when I was hey
Bill Bellamy it's one of the reasons he
he endorsed me to be on Def Jam when I
tricked Bob some into taking a phone
call for me I caught up the I had Def
Jam off his number
and I was like man I need to audition I
can't cook did say what is the
procedures or do I say the tape I said I
got a call of dear act like I already
know these [ __ ] I said y'all
just Donnie wit Bobby put him on the
phone the receptionist was like who is I
said never mind look tell detail Bob
she was a wait wait wait wait wait she
put him on the phone was it Daniel I
tricked the researchers ba ba ba ba ba I
had an open for a lot of the guys under
your management or whatever I just want
a shot and he said can you come mr. Li I
said uh I said uh I'm working as Daisy
maybe you got a job how you a real
comedian got a job but I'm sure because
and I had worked after that I had work
with Bill Bellamy and Bill Brown who was
one to drop the seat and um Bob Sumner's
ear up in his brain for him to let me
get an audition and then you got on that
chair I got with you is this this is
like 90 I was doing comedy for six
months when I made Def Jam and did your
life change and it didn't change the
reason why I didn't change at that time
for Def Jam you for your life to change
you had to have an explosive set now you
can have a set where you could make some
money for a couple years because there
was such a demand for black comedy that
everybody's doing rooms in the biggest
credit for a black comedian was def
Comedy Jam and you don't saying like you
and he had to be the baddest
[ __ ] you just had to be on Def
Jam the promoter to be like this from
def Comedy Jam the brand sold itself
hopefully you get one the marquee people
but if not used to getting somebody from
Def Jam so with me I was really young
when I made it I made it
Def Jam I was doing counting for six
months and I taped that Jam I was doing
counting for eleven months I was green I
didn't know nothing about those bright
lights whatever I told a story about
this fat kid taking my bike when I was a
kid it was my signature bid in DC it was
a bit where it was animated I acted out
but I'll be honest myself when it's
explosive
I keep it real real I thank Michael
Blackson for me even making the cut
because when you take Def Jam is for
comics they take one person always gonna
get cut
everybody didn't make one person and
whoever had to do not the wackest but
the least funny there's one get cut and
that and I'll be honest it was me some
anthony uh anthony uh name was Steve are
you dumb my brain is catching fight now
Anthony Anthony J Anthony Bradley JMP
Brown some more this guy named Y J
Anthony Brown some more Wyatt
meet was four five take me Michael
Blackson and my set was just okay
Michael Blackson destroyed the role
Michael Blackson was ripping this room
just demolishes from its going crazy and
at the enemy say you are a damn it in in
the middle of a standing up it with the
African you muddy [ __ ] us you want time
after you know what that mean and did
everybody wet well you said I have a big
dick everybody's like uh uh that you
want to see my dick day was like yeah
and they thought it did this before they
pulled out a prosthetic dick at all but
it's five feet long right five feet long
big black Vania a big ass voice big they
start waving it around and it ripped the
room but Def Jam was come down under a
lot of flack oh there's like all right
this [ __ ] is getting too crazy you don't
say it's like come on now y'all put him
out big-ass dicks how far we go take a
big joke it Mike said this far right and
that Mike got cut off of it cuz this set
was he could've closed he got cut
because of that and it gave me the
opportunity on the show but it didn't
like it what it did for me is it started
I can have other conversations with
people you know promoters and different
chef still doing a chitlin circuit but
it's like oh [ __ ] it's a reference point
you know say oh that is a Def Con from
Def Jam and like back then they knew you
buy a joke you told you know I'm saying
it's like ROI Yale he did his joke where
he said I ain't scared I'm not he said
you know y'all not gonna make me nervous
tonight
and then he takes his coat off for turns
around and put on a mic stand he's got a
gun in his back side so they
new him has to do with the gut in the
back you know the tide chris tucker was
known as the pissed off man
cuz with chris tucker made it when chris
tucker was on Def Jam
he got seen by bob sumner Bob Simon was
a talent coordinator I don't know if you
know but he had a really pop popular
black comedy competition called the Bay
Area black it was over in Oakland it was
ran for like 15 or 20 years if I'm not
mistaken what's his name was a couple
times
Oh mr. Cooper yep exactly cool launched
oh yes that launched sir that was the
direct cuz I think about not mistaken
Marcus King who eise abandoned Jamie I
think he was affiliated with some kind
of way but whatever it was when it came
to black comedy that's where you went
and Chris Tucker was a part of that that
competition and Chris Tucker he didn't
win a competition think he came in like
second and at the time Chris Chris
Tucker like six minutes that's it that's
it but you know in his business
sometimes people think you you got out
have sometimes all you need is three
minutes of the right [ __ ] and it's God
he had to look he had the energy you
know I'm saying he was energetic he was
happy he was friendly and he just had
this energy against six minutes and
that's all he needed and it was like and
this was this was Def Jam Def Jam was
making people overnight stars on one
tape that's not part of power for the
show was power the show came on at
twelve o'clock Friday nights and you
plan your evening or whatever you're
gonna do it happen after Def Jam came
off and I remember Chris tuck in our set
is on different platforms when Kristen
came up and said pissed off man you know
some people just got it just he said
pissed off man he said I'm so broke if a
[ __ ] rob me and it just be practiced
and he did some [ __ ] and it was Bernie
Mac ain't skinny muffle this pal adele
givens these big lifts and your little
dick would be like giving a whale a
tic-tac pow
it got so bad joint that [ __ ]
was like writing catchphrases they were
like oh if I get to this shucky ducky
quack quack something that people can
remember
you from people's eating off of it I can
still see Joe Torre and recite his
routine yeah Joe Toye was one of those
breakaway Martin Lawrence I could beside
his routine there was a bit he and
Martin
it was just Martin was man it was just
such a lot of people I don't know they
know the story but Martin wasn't the
first option for def Comedy Jam
it was Robin Robin Robin Robin Harris
wonderfully used to mimic whatever funny
funny [ __ ] stop joking and growl
good good [ __ ] you can feel it
but you know in his passing they was
looking for that was Robin um that was
Robin Harris show he passed
Martin was bubbling and next thing you
know that was it and like and they I
think the show Def Jam kind of suffered
when Martin left because he just stamped
with so much as when you heard Def Jam
you heard of mark noise and no
disrespect to Joe Torre or all the other
attempts they made but mark was just so
likable you know I'm saying he was so
likable and he had that gift to be able
to be um insulted without being
offensive you know I'm saying like he
could get you right there like oh you
know and then he'd bring you right back
and he ma'am I did so much Martin
Russell Simmons and Stanley them did so
and Bob Simon did so much for black
comedy man they created a platform when
it didn't exist when all you had was
late like David Letterman you know he
had those late nights er goods and late
late night shows with how often do you
see a black person owes you all he ever
did and they found that need and desire
and it filled it and made some careers
man really that show really made some
Chris from 95 to 2000 huh black Tom he
was so huge no matter what town you went
to what club you went to they had one
night a week dedicated man you know
black Sunday black thunder and they
always flew two guys in always sold out
two shows but one of the busiest
african-american shows I ever saw my
life was DeRay Davis
Chicago here's a Sunday night for show
and that was his night he was walking
out they were dirty geez let me tell you
something man this is that that was the
that was the hustle I had it like he
didn't even need to leave there every
city on the gram was a month ish how
many people job like 12 but did Joey
that was like that was all in on urban
scene that was the hustle hustle hustle
like he's like everybody and in hustle
went to different cities and then we
created like the black circuit we
created our own tours but we called them
runs you know I'm saying you knew like
dr8 we have a night and then somebody
else is having to do this South Florida
good dude glasses been there since
Marvin Dixon Marvin Marvin this is
another example you know I had a Roman
on in Brooklyn New York it was called
pop knockers but it was called poke
Nagas and it was it's like this West
Indian restaurant and we would do we
would do like we would do 4,000 at the
door and then food and drinks to do like
10 12 thousand this was on a Monday
night and like you say it like just
smart comedies the ones the
entrepreneurs
you can see how dear ace becomes so so
successful like we had not like to dope
dudes in the city you had a night that
you can eat off of I was a struggling
comment for you to have one night where
I could pay my rent I was gonna have a
lot of bills but that's when you know
when you adapt DeRay did it um
DeRay did it Bernie Mac before Bernie
Mac blew up on Def Jam he had the cotton
club down in Chicago
yeah I heard stories about yeah but the
only thing but the only thing about it
joy was like with these pop-up black
shows or whatever and then like people
started like like looking down certain
clubs and stuff they will look down on
black comedy do you know they would just
lump anybody if you just said
[ __ ] you realize all he's one of
Def Jam acts you know I'm saying and
then a lot of people didn't like didn't
respect someone to stand up from here so
now you got there it's no it's gonna
only go last for a certain amount of
time you got that certain type of money
but now you got you don't have to do
mainstream but you know do
people that know about you got more
opportunity is not too many um it's not
too many black comics that have built a
very very successful career just off the
black audience what we have no way now
we have chocolate sundae chocolate
sundaes we have D rain Monday Monday
then they they made it they went small
with it at the Comedy Store
Thursday night upstairs Michelle Murdoch
now when I got to this town if you
wanted an agent a manager a movie you
had to be at one of those nights right I
wasn't a big chocolate thunder guy that
is one time and bomb that guy didn't
like me houki the chicken this I'm
talking ninety-eight okay I know it's
wind
what's miss mr. dolls who was obviously
did crisp answer you're right and then
Webber used to go there Chris Webber
yeah what's going there with the black
model yo Chris Webber was a deaf he want
to be a stand-up because yes he was he
was with the Wizards um he used to
always be at the comedy spots man so I
used to go to that one Joe Torre - Joe
that time from Indianapolis one guy
Torry had felt his iron and Joe have and
they had a partner solid brother yeah
well I still asked about yesterday he
threw me up on there you know and that
was 35 hours in those days people don't
know it 30 final half on a Tuesday what
[ __ ] man when I was they would have ribs
and [ __ ] that we gonna catered for MA
and you got to eat free and you gotta
you free and she know about to drink to
drink thinkin she drink tickets and you
can walk with your 30 you has something
[ __ ] muhfuckas be like they give you
$30 I got a drink $15 [ __ ] give
me that drink leave me the [ __ ] alone in
the improv had money man that was
officially
first of all Joe Torre's room on
Tuesdays was where they went to see
Chris Spencer for American History X oh
yeah but they gave it to guy gallery I
didn't know that story and then they
went to see Joe Torre for fifth
dimension and again
a guy Chris Tucker yeah they'd be like
stop come to my mother I still remember
being a telemarketer at the store huh
and the main room seats 450 people and
they would get a hundred industry people
real not oh yeah I'm talking the supply
room on the ones when you see the mother
write on a piece of paper like but
Monday night at the Empire was the night
that was it's not like Spike Davis
despite David Starr dead behind the
eight this is when it was Ariel Spears
Corey Miller Zoo oh yeah zoos fire zoo
and 98 I don't see people doing it that
much anymore like my mall alternate
all-time comedians would go at the end
of this it'll be thank you I've been
least I'd rather like people don't
really do that and is that what people
would do it so like the industry would
be like oh [ __ ] okay that improv did it
right what the improv did was the whole
corner it's been like 25 30 years to 20
yeah so this is 98 if you got a triple
crown [ __ ] it was good that means you
did Latino and I don't know what it
called a hat-trick hatchery yeah then
you ran over to the I improv and did
freaky Monday I don't remember that but
I know your triple the whole freaking
Monday why do you change your voice when
you say that like no I lifted no more yo
you like it's a secret time okay I'll so
there's my uncle Joey Phil Jones all
right now Felton you better change your
tone what's that white dude that's got
the neighborhood make sure are just
arrived I'll make mr. Li he's a permit
for somebody is a perfect but when he
takes you into low ranges don't do this
to me I'm a twenty bus and perverted
[ __ ] but uh freakin Monday was very good
very industry strong the host went up
and they would put a five-minute
act up black or white getting his chops
and then the lineup would start at 9:07
a those seven and it was you know five
young killers
at 8:35 they put on the hottest white
dude working Pablo Doug Stanhope good
[ __ ] like that right then the
african-americans who started it would
be Bernie dr. bass died in that room
bruh and I still remember going like six
or seven times and going I'm on to
something and then [ __ ] stand on one
out one night and he goes it's easy to
jump over a fire hydrant there's a [ __ ]
and Chris Tucker was up on stage and I
have two room laughs there's the joke
was funny huh he didn't mean it in the
racist way Chris doctor heard it he
yells get that white [ __ ] off
the stage and that was it the room went
silent guess who's gonna follow that you
yes they called the fighting moments and
dog I wanna pet a cricket really they
just turned oh they could you
represented that crack that white mother
yeah anybody just died a slow death yo
usually I'll be back I did come back I
came back with two or three other times
and then it just got too rough it was to
the book exchanged and whatever but
those were the nights if you don't
wanted an Asia
you have black but then but the thing
but thing people don't understand
Joe just like what's like you don't
understand it kinda like like writing
like it's weird now cuz you go places
people try to set the list a certain way
and they be talking about well he's not
gonna be the follow dad they try to
paste the show but you always got to be
ready to have a defining moment I came
up one time and I think I you know I get
my [ __ ] off on stage and I'm back in the
um and uh and did the main room at the
Comedy Store and you was up and I was
like god damn dude this [ __ ]
every joke felt like he buddies say good
night oh [ __ ] what you do use what you
sink or swim and I was like [ __ ] that I
just love being a situation where I
muhfuckas either wanna count you out
what are you gonna see what's next
and did step to the
so many [ __ ] now they did so
weak when it comes that [ __ ] it's so
weak with it and it's like that our
business is like our era I was in
competition but the way we flow it only
brings out the best in a [ __ ]
yes it does it does late with all you
ain't trying to I think Neal brilliant
said some time when I was cuz he was
coming behind me he said are we doing
closes I'm like [ __ ] I'm doing
whatever I'm doing whatever I need to do
to [ __ ] this crowd that's it that's a if
your job I don't give a [ __ ] if you like
I'm working on this Bluebird to it guess
what I would figure out to work that
[ __ ] but my job when I go did is smash
that [ __ ] whether I'm in like you know
I came up from a school of my fat doctor
the old school guy from DC he was a
mentor to a lot of people and we talked
about working out people feel like we
need to work out you got to always just
do straight new shits like man you get
them [ __ ] going throw that new
[ __ ] in the middle somewhere and then do
your [ __ ] you know you got a where you
are I'm working I mean they do it
[ __ ] do that I'm working on
this and I just I don't know I'm just
like I feel like that [ __ ] gonna be in a
moment and just once you get it that
rule is it's gotta be a mom it's not
what I wrote I feel like this there's
never what I wrote on the page is how I
feel how I feel is gonna sell a job more
than anything you know saying you feel
[ __ ] up
you got a well written job that [ __ ]
sound like you're a [ __ ] writer
Darnell you got together with royale
who's a sweetheart of a guy okay I was
here for the Royale blow-up with the TV
show and everything they built alas yeah
although way he left me he left that's
what I'm uh [ __ ] love you was here yo
he got speed it yeah man speaking yo he
was a old man from my where I came up
whatever I'm gonna tell you built a less
is a reason why I got the brownstone he
had he had a brand he was written a
brownstone right and it was a dope
brownstone that mother we was broke as a
[ __ ] but we had a dope
brownstone and he had an above
around swimming pool the beggining [ __ ]
the guy who owned the building he had to
hear to brownstones he split the fence
in the middle opened it up African do
work for a bank
he opened up they had above-ground
simple that's not exciting to a lot of
people but for [ __ ] Brooklyn New York
just say you got a pool and I remember
Roy you're like you yeah I didn't even
talking about was on on this side of it
he was poppin brother
yo he had a TV show built to last but
you gotta be selective on how you name
shows cuz you can't name a show where
critic can [ __ ] you up [ __ ] they would
just say built to last
won't you're not saying it wasn't met
with really no but but here's the thing
and the way I look at stuff as much as
critical people when they say Oh didn't
last or where ever they felt about it
that month I did something dead a lot of
people I started with as people I'm
still rocking with now have never got to
you mean have you ever got to sit at the
big table where [ __ ] saying NBC
it's like you got you ever been in an in
part of it an announcement when NBC dues
they're far line up and you was on that
[ __ ] and then Angela Bullock whatever
care whatever that [ __ ] is speed you
want some other [ __ ] and I remember
because the [ __ ] just left New
York
he said I'm moving he did it say [ __ ] to
me that mother [ __ ] left but he left
me a good situation I just had to find
another roommate but I remember he took
off and he felt a lot of success earlier
in his career which I think has really
helped him become a better businessman a
better producer he does a lot of like a
lot of our specials he has relationships
with so many people edges it became hard
I think that getting that must have sex
so early on and seeing how it could
fleet and but not by your design just
how [ __ ] happens what you gonna do now
and I know he's he twit through that
from like his Papa Department like whoa
is slow it's slow but what could I do
now reinvent myself I'm still under
stand up but like like Method Man said
I'm tired of being a chump in the front
I want to be the Mac and
you know but it's so cool that you knew
that story because he was God I'm a guy
Nene I could see his whiskey you seem so
goddamn happy you can see wisdom teeth
in the back it's like a mouth bear
when did she poked him in fear life
Chappell came into my life he came into
my life before I even met him and the
reason why I say that in DC not too many
people leave to go to New York or to LA
yes - hardest thing for a [ __ ]
do they be scared shitless of it some
people do it and come back I'm older
than they but Davis older than me in
comedy so when I first started when I
first started in DC I was on the
Guinness not being cocky I was on fire
you can tell any actually buddy I was
literally smoking I was doing for six
months I was doing it for three years I
was the name coming out of DC you know
you leave somewhere what's the name you
go back for Christmas and all that type
of [ __ ] you like what's the name and I
said I was like um who is uh MPB to tell
me yo you know who getting it I'm like
who this young [ __ ] Dave Chappelle ya
young [ __ ] right come to Holly like
he's 16 and 17 he gettin money son I
mean yeah that's why I say DC he get
money young he up there he don't stay he
[ __ ] with the white boys ages and [ __ ]
and and how you said say cuz I thought I
was on fire and I'm saying to myself
[ __ ] make this [ __ ] so funny
it was no competition or anything right
it did [ __ ] my place here he'd look at
me and say well he's young right like
I'm all old and swell [ __ ] there's
like he's young he's uh he's smart he's
animated and then this is something that
a lot of comments in him they said well
my friend Mike what'd he say
and he he asked all his [ __ ] out you
don't mean like that means if you doing
that producing the records I receive as
an actor you don't saying you got people
to tell a joke but when they said that
you know as I he act all his stuff out
he good his story tell he's everything
that embodies a DC comic so I I would
acts about him and he told he's shared
this story on my birthday two years ago
and Chris Spencer said
how did you be done he said and Dave
reverse the story said you know they
said I had to pop it in New York I was
the man I used to going to DC I used to
act like who's popping and then he said
I would always hear the regular names
Baba bah they said but they got this one
[ __ ] named Donna Roberts it gave
said he was like man [ __ ] that [ __ ]
right because I'll think is like we give
him props but we don't want to give
props so when I moved to when I when I
finally moved to New York commit Dave
Casillas it would come around to the
boss accounting club on black night but
he would do Main Street he did all the
clubs and then it was just it was that
relationship we had as being two
[ __ ]
there was Thoreau from DC that connected
us there was that it was it wasn't like
hanging out it was we met I think the
best way to meet or engage somebody is
respecting them respect their reputation
of what you hear about you know I'm
saying that's how that was our
connection this was years before the
even the birth of Chappelle show
so you're cooking you you know you're in
New York you're making it happen any
acting class I never took a acting class
I I don't know if I'm a great actor I
think I can get an onion past it but
what I would do i took i would get
monologue books and this practice
monologues in the mirror and [ __ ] and
this was this weird thing this goes back
to what you said earlier about that
three-year period with all you thinking
about is creating all you feel like you
thinking about your life or your feet
see like this is it and I just was just
thirsty to do anything yeah I started a
sketch group out of New York before in
living color and I started this group
because I noticed with my stand-up it
was very three-dimensional I have
characters my uncle this fat dude I was
like wait you make Matt could turn this
into some I could take these jokes and
start casting it casting different
people and it casts a mighty play my
mother and Castle my play
Tyrone's so I knew that I could take I
was getting opportunity to stand up but
nobody knew me as an act or anything I
say but I wanted what's the next level
what's the next level of this so I said
I can write these jokes I can cast these
people I got friends someone start this
group start this group called secret
society and the time rare grant was in
the group area hunters she was a poet so
I was hitting with the poetry side Mike
Epps was in the group good friend of
mine Jimmy Martinez rich marked Theobald
now writes for uh he writes for the last
Shoji Cheri Devi
Jason on doors I had a like 12 people
and nobody it was a most diverse sketch
group in New York nobody was doing
sketches and we did a showcase I told my
manager time his company was just
starting and I was like man we should
this is something different nobody's
doing it let's say we can get a night at
Caroline's and showcase the sketches did
I do an act them out so you know the
industry didn't know exactly what he
wanted so some kind of way a lot of
industry came out we did this we did
this a showcase and the next day my
managers phone was ringing off the hook
and uh we we had four agencies that
wanted to sign us we chose to go in APA
any time I was a fourth largest
television is by coast fourth largest
television agency in the country and
they wanted to sign me and somebody else
and they didn't want to sign the whole
group but because I got there with the
group I said I'm not gonna sign you guys
unless you sign the whole group and it
was the first time uh for exact casting
calls where you'll see people names do
you just see secret society like wu-tang
like like you got everybody audition
there whoever wins wins you know but
that was my relationship with New York
and trying to do things to get seen and
get knows I tell people all the time you
gotta be able to
I think in this business you got to be
able to do what the next man won't do or
I haven't thought about stony way and we
don't do that you surrender [ __ ]
use the Dolomites I haven't seen it yet
I've got to see everything
I keep hearing about it I keep hearing
that and I don't know the act was good
but I feel what's resonating is the
story of dolomite of how he was a
maverick
you know first one is making his own
comedy albums Lisa now movie theater did
you see it yet yes did you enjoy it very
much
very much I enjoyed the black experience
you know I'm afraid of black experience
I enjoyed he says something in there
that really it strikes a chord with you
especially when you're an open my
grandma point of view opened my career
he tells Michael he was a that makes
sense though man
you know and it's just it touched me a
lot of ways you know like I said when I
came from Cuba the first family and take
me in was an african-american family in
the 70s which is completely different
afro picks with the hand in it I had a
whale tells you she was original
different strokes yeah yeah with the
thing and you know I still remember the
mentality and I still remember how sad
lays the whole building would have a
talent contest you did laws you still
beat you win it's either black people
have a community room in the basement
and you would go down and there'd be a
hundred black families you'd have to say
what dancer tap dance and I still
remember me and
this kid that his last name was Williams
and I still think about him we won
because we sang Joe Tex I got you oh oh
yeah I'll take a question did when when
when you have a moment like that did you
think you were gonna be in the business
of entertainment not even close
no the point I want to make from the
story is how they entertain themselves
these people were poor you know and when
you went to the house it was a bologna
sandwich and they gave me a half and the
grape kool-aid and they gave me a glass
and you know I slept on the floor with
the brothers and sisters whatever the
[ __ ] they got I got you know but but the
thing that strikes me the most about it
was the love nobody else would like me
when I was yeah except this and I still
remember walking into those projects and
there be some sighs but you had to be a
real [ __ ] to know five years old
you was a real father I felt something
about you walking there skin there we go
you know what the [ __ ] was his name dr.
ray and they were yelling what we do
with that white [ __ ] I'm
bringing him in the building he white
[ __ ] cubed right nobody knew nothing
about nothing you know but I learned a
lot no I did not think anything about
the entertainment business it made me
fall in love with they taught me about
our Chi loud on the drowse they taught
me about The Supremes
I still remember get maybe see people
love to love man I loved it I loved
everything about people love man black
people love to [ __ ] Allah and black
folks man we not the only race but this
is because I know it like our
circumstances could be the worst
circumstances in the world but we will
figure out a way to laugh and we will
[ __ ] a figure out a way to stay up death
therapist couch you know I'm saying like
we
like that's why they take they talk
about like mental health issues whatever
they always say what black people afraid
to get help whatever they're afraid to
get but somehow [ __ ] don't need to
get help it's just like you got to step
your coping mechanisms up we all go
[ __ ] crazy we all have bad days but
it's how you cope with [ __ ] you know I'm
saying and then another reason you know
you know and I'm not speaking for black
male like watch percent but man
[ __ ] are so [ __ ] nerves of
pills you know when you go talk that
straight you leave it with a
prescription you go get something set if
you black the average black person if
you sit down with a [ __ ] shrink
long enough he's gonna find you a
prescription and a prescription could
possibly be trying to cope with [ __ ] I
know the mental health [ __ ] is real but
how [ __ ] cope you can't suck
nothing up everything got a goddamn
acronym you know I'm saying like oh man
this waters warm he's several BS water
syndrome you know what every time he
gets any drinks water he's just crazy
he goes appears appeal his bill black
people been through so much you have to
learn how to laugh you could be
miserable and upset all the time what I
was getting to that what I saw in those
projects early on the 70s do you know
what memories rehash those memories
what's that
and why so I felt that black love again
I felt that human your sketches with fit
with did you did they resonate through
said the performance I would like just
to kind of lean on Dave's is 94 I know
Dave since Robin Hood Men in Tights
when the Boston Common yo Joey is so
funny you said and and this is no shade
or anything and this is about when you
family on the right team or you build
the right team Dave Chappelle probably
had 11 pilots
yes he did a lot of people don't know
this company by the boy 11 he was
getting shots and shots and shots ABC
has Dane he's a white dude
Jim pure no another one of the big-time
like dude I don't know what a big-time
white good-looking white dudes like Greg
Kinnear I'm not sure at some point ask
him like what a toy him 98 97 they kept
trying to make David star from early but
he left on the property he was a he was
a gold it was it was the one and I you
know for 11 pilots which are my eleven
pilots and he probably would even to
economy 11 years at the time his company
a pilot boy and it was this little show
and just you know following up what you
say this file the love and how you felt
there was something about this show
there was something about the connection
Neal Brennan had with Charlie Murphy it
was something about Charlie Murphy was
something about me it was something
about Anthony berry it was something
about all of those [ __ ]
background people that was on that show
it was something that was loved and it
felt like my father's trying it was
about I'm getting paid this and I need
top billing cuz what nobody getting paid
[ __ ] the only thing my father's was
doing was trying to create the most the
funniest [ __ ] she could and for you to
say that that's how it felt bruh you
know I'm saying like even when Dave and
Neil had reservations about the
shoulders and all this and that I used
to predict how the radios gonna be I was
like man this [ __ ] about to blow and it
was like cuz they'd been through it they
dealt with rejection I don't know that
I'm still like that three knee and nut
you talking about life huh I'm like man
I like I'm telling y'all and the reason
why I knew it is big this Weidner was
one blow
because I heard [ __ ] in the hood
talking about Dave Chappelle and what I
mean by that Dave Chappelle when he
first started he came out the gate
mainstream fat boys loved him colleges
loved him super smart people loved them
but in a and I think in a black
community they didn't get him yet you
know they didn't get him yet but it was
just something about this show
was like when they started popping into
barbershops when it started popping on
on on a block and [ __ ] like that that's
when I was like man this is something
special you know this is something
special and I was like because Dave had
every audience but that really really
Street [ __ ] it didn't connect it not
that you need that but it's something
about Brian Tucker and just something
about the team that they put together
that understood all of that it connected
with every part of it I think that was
one of the things that made that show so
dope how many seasons two and a half yes
and then and then nothing you know not
to take with Dave's like it's easy
writing for a superstar and dave was a
superstar Dave's type superstar where
you can have shitty writers and he still
won't flip it you know so you got that
combination you already had a game and
then you got a team of people to put
together and that dude was like you know
I we work together I remember one
particular time we were it was seen with
Patrice O'Neal he was playing pitbull he
was one of the original players it was
rich vos me Dave Charlie Murphy and
Yoshida Asian dude you know we were
working on 16 hours man we was tired I
don't never think I would ever say I was
I was joked out I was choked to [ __ ] out
and we had to look at this board of
pictures and [ __ ] and and just roast
them and nobody you know we was looking
like this Patrice's bag - gasps Oh
Patrice and Dave been roasting each
other all day before we were rolling the
cameras we got the cameras rolling
everybody gets out of Justin was just
pause it was a picture of Rosie
O'Donnell and Dave saying she looks like
she worth jaws with big holes in the
back right yo you see this laughs Joey
this laugh was like where the [ __ ] did
he get this from and that was him all
the time and at the same way we talked
about being at comedy clubs when you go
hard and let the [ __ ] far away for
that's how it was when we were working
on show you know he would do something
and then everybody did creative or go
and didn't everybody's like Oh what
about this what about this and then [ __ ]
would just pop that month ago always
came through always get on one thing you
learn from Dave there's a comic really
being connected to who you are in your
true self and that just on this day's
just in life
you're not saying like what is your true
self and being your true self and then
like you know it's hard to immolate just
but haven't your calm while you do it I
don't think I ever if ever even say they
raise his voice you know and just as I
watch him as a performer and I'll say
like I'll I say he's like um a Tom Brady
and when I say that like he knows how to
lay in the pocket you know I mean he
don't scramble like chaotic like huh you
know like me like I say I'm like Michael
Vick ish I'm said [ __ ] that I'll try to
run that [ __ ] down the to hole every
time I know we got a pass play but I run
his [ __ ] I'm gonna run it but he's
like when I say time ready get in the
pocket did calm his beer wait wait wait
wait and good take a hit at the boom and
he's going to touchdown you know and I'm
like he's like a a day was just a good
person man you like a good person you
feel that I travel with him people
always like even with me it's
unfortunate sometimes because the work
I'd done on Chappelle's Show easily
probably overshadows anything I've ever
done so do I get the credit for being on
HBO's - why you're do I do the credit
for being on the corner do I get a
credit of you and I both had that
[ __ ] gangsters cameo spider-man
[ __ ] you're not saying I've done of a
lot of stuffs but that for something
about their show is just where everybody
everybody connects to that [ __ ] very
interesting something you said I had the
honor of working with Dave what what
years with Chappelle show that had to be
that was like somewhere around 2000 to
2003 yeah I had a little work with David
99 in Miami now the Miami improv at the
time was in Coconut Grove I remember I
closed that Club bill yeah not that
closed down but I was a yeah I'm there
next week and they had some yo they got
that Cuba dressed you down there I can't
wait
yeah a new place and I'm not you
cuddling you're talking about the old
one in Coconut Grove
no I'm talking about I'm excited about
the new one but I know Coconut Grove and
this reason why I was safe and I don't
mean cut you up but that was one of the
best places because they cater to the
Cuban they had that [ __ ]
Argentina's fake as [ __ ] side I'm like
this is what the Improv I right yes they
had Hamish with the stuffed they had a
very Cuban influence me so I know you
probably have a ball and the Italian
restaurant downstairs yes yeah I
remember that [ __ ] frozen drinks
default that did the [ __ ] white just
walking down a little strip down into
salad bars I don't think I ever
[ __ ] was in love with smoothies
[ __ ] to us i don't white kids walking
danny with them with the muhfucka let me
Lou lose his [ __ ] I don't lose but
Monday and Tuesday after the man at the
Miami improv was african-american night
Marvin Dixon huh so Marvin Dixon would
give away tickets now with a thought
without a phone cuz you know you just
pull his clothes off yeah yeah the
tickets get give shake it out on the way
out
and not to sound you know whatever it's
it's a different type of brother Marvin
no no the tickets he was given away huh
Liberty City [ __ ] brothers right
ain't play right and I still opening up
for chappal some of those free ticket
guys would come up grillak the audience
had 250 people in it 100 whites 100
Latinos cube
and maybe 50 people 49 new Dave
Chappelle was but the ones from Def Jam
Monday that's what that's the point I'm
saying they would walk out yeah walk out
on a day and I'm going I don't
understand this because you was the
reason why your your your mind was like
well say everybody not ready for
everything you know I'm saying that's
what I'm saying
it was when the Chappelle show popped
off that the hood start getting a
connection and I'm telling you I see me
rallies like a lot of it like
[ __ ] it knows like the depth
the the real real gangster nights a lot
of [ __ ] didn't want to think
about the comedy Dave makes you think
about the joke
they makes you think about the joke
David's not gonna be Papapa he makes you
think about he's always been there he's
always been from 17 to 16 he was funny
but socially conscious you're my husband
doing a Hennessy and eating them lemon
pepper chicken we don't worry about that
[ __ ] they don't want him uh fun to think
like that and like I say there's no
shade whatever anybody knows that coming
up but that Chappelle show
that's when it seemed like everything
connected I for him I still remember
doing him a Tuesday night there cuz
Marvin would always hire me
right I was the feature act so mom would
give me a hundred a show for Monday and
Tuesday in the early just to take care
right Ivan was a silent little brother
yeah and I still remember being in there
a Tuesday night and Chris Rock walking
in that [ __ ] with Madonna and
Chris Rock was on stage and then
brothers weren't going for it but they
had forks and spoons they would hit the
glasses thinking oh man you kind of said
this means get buff yo you understand
Marvin Dixon Marvin Dixon's rooms and
Bruce Bruce rooms where first off it was
with Bruce Bruce at move with his room
Bruce Bruce room was in um and was it
fun Elena was Atlanta was Atlanta no
Bruce room was Florida one in a
[ __ ] southern Josh but they had
to to toughen Marvin Dixon where
everybody knew because the reason why
because Marvin never really stabs the
room as a comedy room he stabs as a
spectacle
like he used to talk the fact that he
had 300 standing ovations in a row you
know easy as get an ovation if at the
end of the song
you dropped don't stop get it get it in
a man strips down to a [ __ ]
thong and start dancing they not level
with you they laughing at you and that's
what he established in that room so I
could probably tell you people have
ripped up robbing people to didn't
ripped everybody's wedding fit for that
but those were I remember Bruce Bruce
told me one time in this room he said
look man I'm gonna get your money now
like like we're doing a drug deal he's
having game right now
just do your ten minutes and get the
[ __ ] out of here two-door that way you
know like those guys they built a room
about round their personality so much it
was hard for anybody do good and I'm in
Miami
Bruce brew where was it Miami Miami I
mean I met Bruce Bruce room and I I said
something I said
yeah all y'all stripper [ __ ] are here
Joe I did not realize that how we
suspected of a job that was like they
looked at me like oh we gotta give him
money he talked about [ __ ]
livelihood and those Romans was just it
was like those those was a fast ones if
you didn't like you saying you should
come out and just start [ __ ] them up
I tell people didn't you get a few been
doing while you learn you like okay it's
gonna be tough for him this way I got to
do I got to make an example of somebody
I'm sorry sir I know no disrespect but
I'm about to tell your ass right
I gotta do it and all you gonna come on
oh no he didn't x2 you know bow they
listening now because of you I'm gonna
call in next week and go to D Ray's room
yeah do it it's it's been 10 years I'm
sitting here and looking at you going
why is it that well at the store I would
always go on 4G guy with always just
come looking for Ringo
we got a five minute gap to get in there
real quick it's after those won the
challenge joint is like in like it's so
many reasons it's so you could come up
with a million reason why you don't want
to go to your whatever but for me and
you know like I work eight clubs now you
know saying I do the store laugh back
right there anything
I'm a marquee [ __ ] but it's just
something in me every once in a while I
just got to go do it when I go to New
York it's so it didn't another thing I
feel like you like because of some of
the success I've had when my resume
speaks probably more than my bank
account does when i goaded like when I'm
in Brooklyn and I go he's well off spots
they look people give me they look at me
like [ __ ] you doing here I'm like I'm a
comic and I started here and it just and
like for me to go to those spots like
they'd be freaking out Joey like oh [ __ ]
I'm like man I'm never gonna I'm never
ever gonna forget what these rooms did
to me did for me these rooms pay my rent
you know I'm saying these rooms gave me
a place to practice these roads was
everything to me
and I'm never gonna stop nevertheless I
remember when Dave Chappelle had his
residency at uh at the Radio City
musical 6500 people like 17 days in a
row
two nights and I was questioning [ __ ]
two nights after standing up 6,500
people I getting to call my man and
drive to Brooklyn to perform for 30
people in Brownsville and gave them
[ __ ] the same [ __ ] and to be
quite honest be quite honest felt better
about those 35 [ __ ] they're
saying I ain't think oh man do it
kid it drink me this just as much we do
this [ __ ] we always got to do something
to make our soul feel good people always
tells you make you make me feel good you
know it's like therapy I need that y'all
don't know [ __ ] y'all out
therapy it's mine it's mine too man Hika
for real
why why why he was working like I am not
working at night I'm going see my
therapist [ __ ]
in his you mother my friend fat doctor
and his health isn't doing that well I
love to do he's a mentor to me mentor to
Tony woods mentioned to Martin Lawrence
really good guys very probably know
a DC Circuit and he used to tell me
Donna that's our that's our life that's
our [ __ ]
he said we deal with regular life he say
but we get on that stage we put that
[ __ ] on the side of the stage we'd do
our [ __ ] don't go away we pick it back
up and we deal with it when we get off
but that's our [ __ ] that's our [ __ ] yo
John with the small pass you know
everybody was like I was just talking to
him I was just talking to him because
that's how he worked that's his life
people that we even have to but this is
like this is our fuel what what else do
we know
Dave excellente said he said when is
your tour over I said never [ __ ]
when I'm dead when I die when I die
Diggy be like he just did a spot in the
belly room what else do we do I love the
fact that if I don't get on stage for
two three nights I go into a different
world my head like a field yeah get on
stage yep like I couldn't get on stage
Tuesday I couldn't get down it cuz I'm I
like it was still swollen right cuz I
fell the MA but [ __ ] Wednesday night I
went down and had a blast the belly room
just had a blast because it's who we are
that's it I got to do it every couple
days I couldn't I couldn't a week or
some of my uh ya know I'll be like what
the [ __ ] is goin like him especially
right now I'm going through because I
did a generation
when did you tape I taped about two
months ago and went over there
December 31st oh I did that I did I did
some stuff where I didn't gave a lot of
my bangers to TV you know says well now
I'm back in the back game right now
and yeah I don't want to see that face
like I heard yeah you know it's his name
some people give whatever that dude all
right yeah I do
okay and now but you'd like I get off
like I watch you do that [ __ ] to a my
god damn
but the thing I feel like I don't know
when I watch you before like you
you're so strong or who you are on stage
you so strong with who you are on stage
that feel like you can throw a light saw
bottle up there and you will catch that
[ __ ] and it'll become twenty minutes
you're not saying like everybody don't
have that skill set to you tell them of
a good beer and just make something
happen
no that [ __ ] make something happen
do [ __ ] gonna get so [ __ ]
nervous because my focus to not want to
trust that what supposed to be you up
there is that you are a funny
[ __ ]
you're just so funny [ __ ] some
up [ __ ] is a pen and paper and I don't
knock it but some of her just funny
just like that [ __ ] when his
worst night he's [ __ ] on y'all best
nights my leg right [ __ ] yo by later
and I still [ __ ] y'all up yo I didn't
want to sit down yo dis leg but [ __ ]
that I would still smoke y'all
[ __ ] how many I mean how many
years you've been doing comedy uh she's
going on thirty twenty
I'm telling guys I'm trying backtrack
time probably like twenty six twenty
five twenty three twenty five yep yep
how do you feel now stronger than your
thumb joint and you still wait to the 35
year more joke I look at Chris and Joe
Rogan those enough unders been doing it
30 years you know you just right this
right this is crazy after 25 years and
I'm not talking about 25k yeah we're
it's a slump or he was wacked from 92 to
93
I'm tumble 25 years of being a Ripper
and I tell this I still feel like I get
better every year every year every year
every goddamn show that I
you know and say and I'm talk about you
know muffin company like [ __ ]
like this oh [ __ ] yo
that [ __ ] funny like but it's
it's not gonna stop
you know I'm span every year and I'm not
again
I'm someone every optimal offer like
last year I was killing [ __ ] where
people are oh yeah that's it
his wig it's always got to find
something else well we evolved like I
love evolving I love writing there's
nothing worse than being excited to see
a comic and watch them eat there's a
tremendous set and also one day you get
an email he's back in town and you go
there and he does the exact same set you
just watched me forever cuz you're
telling me that in a year nothing
happened you're like you didn't even
take a [ __ ] man you know I'd say the
best compliment the most appreciated
compliment I get is when the
[ __ ] come up to you I'm saying
just my fifth time seeing you there you
come in five tired anyway flippin yeah
if you ain't flipping any comeback yeah
like I don't even like to go like I got
a little Atlanta in January I won't go
to Nashville but in April because half
of those Atlanta people gonna drive from
natural I already know it I got go to DC
I do DC Thanksgiving weekend this is the
tough not to tell this is the this what
again coming
yeah that's coming yeah this weekend
coming because uh I um that's my
hometown that's like been my traditional
shelf like you left us last so Friday
say somebody do you see it Friday
Saturday Sunday yeah this been my
traditional show you know but it's so
challenge because you went [ __ ]
did you grow up with stuff coming your
shows it's a different level of heckler
and did you start here people yellow
today ain't Darnell like the only way a
[ __ ] high school good you like
oh he wasn't [ __ ] he was in gym class
with me and I do that every year like
right now I got a I got a I got a do a
remix not man I know God we gonna see
what happens you know we must see what
happened because I was just there I just
did birch me a while ago and then I just
exhausted so much I'm just in that place
where once I just gotta get up
something's gotta pop and did you know
once you get that groove you just right
you like Dan that's [ __ ] 20 minutes
right there it's so crazy now right now
the back of your mind you're in hell and
you'll be in hell for another month then
you'll come up with four minutes there's
some you know like rock this something
this guy does something now you got six
minutes but then you put together a ten
minute run right and guess what you
could had three from a joke you have for
me yes go and you stop put it together
ready [ __ ] like this is when I did my
last set that I had I had to chop it up
for Netflix to do some other stuff but I
was like man this is gonna be my dope
hour but the nobody was coming to me for
our it was coming with 50 mins here 20
mins air I'm like man I ain't saving
[ __ ] how's it the way I get an hour is
smash it so like even on the Netflix
joint I literally took 45 minutes of
[ __ ] trimmed all the fat off and got
straight to bah-bah-bah oh and I had to
sacrifice it's like well you should have
said it for your Netflix busted Netflix
they give me a hour to get me 15 minutes
in this and that'll give me the other
one but that and I had man I had
disclosing where I had to begin in the
middle I had a callback an attack and
then my last joke I had three callbacks
no for callbacks from the entire set so
it was i pop-up in at the end
Bam Bam Bam and I just Maps up the same
it's gonna force me to go harder though
so December 31st 7 31st and I'm gonna go
with Martin - I'm doing I'm Martin
Lawrence this is gonna be so nostalgic
Martin Lawrence lit his [ __ ] to her and
he's doing 29 seasons I'm doing like
nine of them earthquake deer a little a
little rail Jay Ferrel Tommy Davidson
it's a mix of everything a mix of
different people I got seven days but
for me to grow up like looking at Martin
Lawrence it's like a bucket list [ __ ]
just yeah just to be able to shake his
hand come and watered all space gonna be
dope good for you man you got a website
where they can find on your wrongs calm
down
Joey you know I've been coming down
there I'm glad we had this type of
interview I've been coming under a lot
of attack on that I talk too much and
I've heard people saying I don't know
when to shut up and I talk too much so
I've taken that energy and I've started
my own podcast so I could talk my
[ __ ] ass off is called the down
a rolling show
it's be out you sure you probably can
get it right now go to your table at
anywhere I'm so bootleg all right yo I
want you to check it out no you get sick
of it but I just just I'm excited about
it I know I'm gonna do yeah yeah we got
you know it's fun you won't let me and
Kate but it's just I watched it
yesterday and I was like this is
different it just feels so real and so
dope even our chemistry you know say cuz
you see her when you first see it you
see a pretty face right and then you get
a couple of a couple of minutes you see
a tomboy and just a cool [ __ ]
she's cool and so every night yeah she's
dope shalyah morning some night
yeah you mean a lot of her life I could
tell every time she no no listen man we
also have the mutual from with the
violin Eliza I love her with all my
heart
guys like you and me we need and it man
that girl Liza when I first before I
moved here it would be like I would have
to do audition or something I didn't
know no way around she would come and
take me to auditions damn you living out
her car you know saying and I see her go
up and down in her life I've never seen
her down
I've never seen a frown I've always I've
always known her to be like it's just
part of it we keep it moving we keeping
more I love it or that's better on the
podcast I love it at that and that
violation peace oh my god she made a
play I told her to bring it I told yo I
was like man talk to cuz you talk to me
right she was like I was like I know you
tell she's like I was like oh I was I
wouldn't say it's not the bad way I was
like [ __ ] if you got to take that
mother for the violin it rock that [ __ ]
she [ __ ] she killed him ride me cry
yes
we [ __ ] cried but bro you always
welcome on my tank I appreciate him as
his family here time you kill me at the
store your energy and I wish you nothing
but love prison and don't forget I'm in
Miami next week December no no no New
York December 6th all that's left is
late tickets you and the other South
Hall yeah we're at Town Hall I'm a big
go to a birthday party
damn I might catch me after bumpy in
town all right I'll be there December 6
Friday all the tickets I got 11 bosses
sold outs all we got left is the second
show the Town Hall it's gonna be a great
show a bunch of [ __ ] showing up
so bring the reefer do what you need to
do and now send me off with some teenage
[ __ ] bout city I talk about you all I'm
just gonna keep it to myself but I'm
happy now for a word from our sponsors
what the [ __ ] you think you're dealing
with I want to thank Donnell Rawlings I
want to thank the [ __ ] [ __ ]
but most importantly I want to thank you
guys first off listen the holidays are
coming it's a whole new [ __ ] everybody
wants to start changing December 31st
they have goals of January 1st I'd do it
differently I get ready now I start
getting ready now you start writing your
goals now you start going on that diet
now [ __ ] the 31st December that's where
all the other jerk clothes right now if
you want to turn your life run you gonna
start with a [ __ ] bidet
because why walk around with a stinky
filthy [ __ ] [ __ ] you don't need
that no more and it's an amazing
unconventional gift that everybody in
your life needs because everybody in
your life has a stinky [ __ ] ass all
or you have to assume ok everybody
deserves the gift of [ __ ] tushy
wiping your butt with [ __ ] dry toilet
paper just removes this [ __ ] but it
leaves the other Malucci in the stink in
the odor you got poop and all this
shit's on our poverty your body you wipe
it off with dry [ __ ] paper what the
[ __ ] are you thinking water cleans
better than dry paper white killed
10,000
trees to wipe that stinky filthy [ __ ]
hole of an [ __ ] you got forget about
it it's right now it's time for you to
get a bidet and if you know somebody you
will look at something you know I wonder
what they're ask Mel's like this that's
some [ __ ] that needs a bidet go
- hello - she doc Tom right now
they got bad days starting at 69
[ __ ] dollars you know sell out
that $69 you got different colors you
got different guaranteed they got towels
to dry your ass listen I know these
people personally I believe in their
product I think they got a 60-day
guarantee it don't matter if me and Lea
haven't cracked it your [ __ ] skinny
ass ain't gonna do nothing don't either
go to hell old toshi calm press in
church and get 10% off your first order
delivered to your house like I said it's
the best gift you could give this year
and it's nice and easy get it delivered
right to their [ __ ] houses if you
don't have hello - she in your house and
[ __ ] portable birthday you're
slipping this is the only country where
we're still wiping our ass with our
[ __ ] hands everybody else just
presses a button and they clean your
balls they steam dry your ass all cuz
she's making big moves gonna hell it'll
push you down calm right now I'm
pressing Church and get 10% off your
order the church is also brought to you
by my bookie listen how much longer how
much [ __ ] long are you gonna sit
there like a montage and not make a
dollar not even a [ __ ] dollar really
really you can't pick a winner that's
what you telling me one [ __ ] game a
week you can't pick yes you can it
starts with my bookie left past present
in my future my bookie plans this
Thursday you're gonna get a game that's
risk free listen put down a turkey leg
and listen go to my bookie dot AG if the
pilgrims are sail to America you could
take a chance on the Bears Lions game
either way you're not gonna lose nobody
that's all right but Thanksgiving Day
only only this Thursday choose a team
against the spread for up to $250 and if
you win you're gonna get some cash for
the holidays if you lose you're also win
because my bookie will give you your
money back this is Thanksgiving with all
the [ __ ] goodies you understand me
quit waiting around
sign up today and get into the [ __ ]
game it's Monday sign up today you can
start tonight with Monday Night Football
carry your winnings to [ __ ] win more
money on Thursday on a guaranteed bet
you can't [ __ ] a moose okay let me
repeat that's a guaranteed deposit match
and a risk-free bet but Thanksgiving
only so if you're a true [ __ ]
football fan and if you're a true
[ __ ] gangster don't let this
opportunity pass you by log in to my
bookie down AG make your first deposit
promo code Church and my book you will
match your deposit dollar for dollar
from the [ __ ] jump and that's top of
the risk-free bet stop waiting the
[ __ ] sidelines start making some real
[ __ ] money I'm gonna drive you but
you ain't gonna do dick you ain't gonna
do dick this is the [ __ ] path to your
[ __ ] with and gamblers anonymous
1-800 gambling 1-800 gamble but for
right now my bookie dot AG [ __ ]
all right use promo code Church you play
you win you get paid I want to take my
bookie I want to thank hello to sheet
that Tom and I also want to thank CBD
Lyon [ __ ] making lives better go to
see BB Lyon doc Tom
do not forget Friday there's just a
couple tickets left in [ __ ] New York
on December 6th I'm sorry this may be 20
tickets left and then Colusa casino on
the 27th of December and the San
Francisco Performing Arts Center
something like that on the 28th there's
a few tickets left up there to knock
yourself out
have a great [ __ ] week this is the
week [ __ ] it's Thanksgiving
gobble gobble kick this [ __ ] mule Lee